il s'appelle abdoulkarim clé elle a
grandi au marigot et est de retour au
pays il s'est converti à l'islam en
suisse il y a quinze ans et comme tous
ses fidèles musulmans il vient ainsi
fêté la rupture du jeûne
l'aïd el fitr est un jour de fête un
jour qui commence par des chants puis
par la prière et musulmans sont
seulement en train de glorifier leur
seigneur de le remercier pour tous les
bienfaits qui le rock leur a accordé et
ensuite après cela l'imam va commencer
son discours
le discours est un prêche que les
musulmans appellent aussi des
bénédictions un discours en arabe et en
français qui rappelle quelques données
fondamentales contenus dans le coran ce
que dieu ordonne ce qu'il interdit et ce
qu'il attend des fidèles continuation de
toutes les religions qui ont évolué
avant comme le judaïsme et le
christianisme en scène la parole de dire
toujours qu'ils continuent à nous c'est
ça qu'on nous appelons d'al-islah la
tolérance envers l'autre respecter
l'autre dans tous ces kilomètres avant
cette célébration les musulmans avaient
jeûné pendant un mois
de la même façon donc le prophète il
incite les musulmans à faire attention à
leur vocabulaire à faire attention à ce
qu'ils disent ce qu'ils font donc durant
ce mois béni donc les musulmans vont
améliorer ont cherché à améliorer leur
comportement durant ce mois et vont
chercher à améliorer donc leur relation
aussi entre eux l'enseignant l'aïd el
fitr sera également fêté samedi avec
l'ensemble de la communauté